microsoft's internet explorer browser is
officially done so it's really it's
extremely nostalgic like that big e blue
e logo with like the yellow ring around
it like that's iconic
and this is just like this is part of
growing up you know
losing loved ones but if they just
unlock a memory i know
like paint what was that game with the
my it's not minecraft tower mine sweeper
icy tower oh acnos energizer yeah yeah
yeah and then aqua the water version
wacky packs do you remember wacky packs
i remember nude
yeah i know what's going on
oh my god miniclip.com it used to be lit
those were the days kids will never know
if you're too busy slapping each other
with tortillas you'll never know the joy
of reaching a new level in aknows
energizer no you'll never know of
reaching a new high score in icy tower
oh that little guy he was flipping he
was bouncing off the walls